emmy i
girl you were so good you transformed
into something absolutely amazing your
voice everything congratulations on your
performance it was absolutely good i
don't know what else to say it was
absolutely amazing and i love the way
the first episode starts with her saying
i'm not a woman i'm an icon and oh
there's my dog he's walking in uh you
know it starts off real like god back
there
here you go uh what now he's barking
what was it like for you to see that
transformation happen
incredible um you know to have have um
uh
to be supported um by this incredible
team of artists
hair makeup prosthetics um costume danny
glicker kate bisco vincent van dyke
they're just they're just epic artists
and
so to have that done on you and to then
spin around in the chair and see the big
reveal and to not recognize yourself at
all is incredibly liberating and
exciting and just brought the character
to life even more
and what did angeline say when she saw
you in that transformation
i mean i i don't know i i i i hope that
she sees the show and absolutely loves
it i hope that you know it's imbued with
her spirit and if she gave me one piece
of advice on playing her it was
i'm a mirror and i served to inspire so
whatever you see that's what you should
play
yeah and for you what did you learn
about i mean she's been around for so
many years those billboard stories were
in the 84 84 i believe right and so what
did you learn about her that you didn't
know
when going into this project
oh so much i think she is an absolute
enigma and i think that what's so
interesting is
is somebody that is so known at least in
la and yet so unknown there are so many
different
stories some very grounded and some
absolutely fantastical often
contradictory stories that go to kind of
build and shape
our perspective on this on this icon
this woman um and i think that's the
most interesting thing about her she's
also never gone out of her way to dispel
any of those rumors because brilliantly
she understands that they just go to
fuel this tumbleweed that that
perpetuates her
her reach and her fame
you know watching this it made me think
about what is the definition of being
famous what's your definition
i think for me um
i'm an actor and so with that and with
getting to do that on a big level comes
fame angeline is
an artist she is
living breathing a piece of art and i
think with that comes fame as well and i
think that comes challenges and interest
from the public in your personal life
but i also think that
it's incredibly
profound to get to share your gift um
and something that is meaningful to you
with people and and have them like it so
i think um
i think it is inextricably linked with
um the honor of getting to do the jobs
that we do
do you do you resonate anyway with her
like has your journey ever been hard for
you to get to this point
me
yeah
of of course
yeah i mean
there are there have been so many um
challenges that that i have overcome and
have um
found um escapism and and
positive um
catharsis through this work um
it is an honor to play uh fierce
trailblazing women
um and to play different characters and
to have those characters connect with
human beings um real living human beings
out there that that watch shows and
movies um
it it it's pretty
soul affirming
really
and there's a beautiful instagram photo
of you two together
which is so great so what was that
moment like for you what was that
conversation and having that i guess
that little moment
well i got the chance to meet her that
night that's at that that picture is
from the hollywood roosevelt hotel and
that's a location that she chose because
she said it was her lucky contract
signing place and um
i met her there i think i was probably
an hour early and way over prepared i
had already bought her meditation tapes
on ebay and memorized everything she has
ever said
um
and i you know she showed up roaring in
the in the pink corvette on time and
then got mobbed by fans trying to buy
t-shirts out of her trunk so she ended
up to be like an hour late which i loved
um
and i you know tried to um tell her how
much i loved her how i admitted how
nervous i was to meet her
and she has
this incredible like childlike spirit
and also this fierceness she said to me
the first time like so why do you have
such a hard time hard on to meet me
um and i just thought that's why she's
really strong and fierce and authentic
and um that's why it was so meaningful
to me to have her blessing to play the
role
that's amazing and i have to know would
you ever go blonde
oh yeah you know right after we rap
shameless actually i i really wanted a
hair change so i went blonde and it
lasted about 18 hours
and then i went no way i was like this
doesn't actually with brown eyes and
brown eyebrow eyes it was not it was not
working but i can tell you after after
wearing these wigs um some of which i i
own now and to comb i i really love it
you